hello my name is the Ginga and I'm
either and I want to tell you today oh
but first I want to tell you about the
law that we have in Norway actually and
inaccessible websites are illegal in
Norway this is a law that has been in
effect this is a lot of in effect since
July 2014 it had unanimous support in
our Parliament it was backed by NGOs and
also the industry in Norway so the hold
industry and everyone is really
basically agreed this is a good idea
let's do it
and then what's interesting also is
often laws like these are just applied
to the public sector but Norway it also
applies to the private sector so if
you're a bank if you're airline you also
have to follow the law and how its
defined is that anything that is can be
considered a main channel to offer
services or information to the general
public has to be accessible that's
pretty broad and thing also so when we'd
say accessibility in this context is
based on the world the web content
accessibility guidelines - oh and not
all of the double-a criteria but most of
them so all the ones that are in green
are under the law we have like a bunch
of links and resources so that were a
link that we share afterwards and then
you can get all of the details if you
want to know and there's the thing is
there's a bunch of countries that also
have these laws but in Norway they can
also have consequences so there's a
state agency called Die fight they make
random controls and check the websites
according to the criteria and published
a report online as this this is the
things that this company has to fix and
his old public and online and I think
it's a year or two years ago v CAG was
actually making headlines in Norway
these are headlines from two of Norway's
largest newspapers on the headline SAS
as a Norwegian airline and the headline
says SAS fails SS as risking fines
interesting thing is like it was in all
of the newspapers it was making
headlines on the story was not only that
it made them look well you know
following the law but it also made them
look incompetent you don't understand
technology because was such a broad
support from the industry and also from
the Parliament it just made them look
stupid
so accessibility is something it's not
really something just a question about
morals anymore in Norway because
something you should I think it's
something you should do anyway but it's
also you're risking bad press finds
stuff like that so back to us this is
our company and this time this is our
entire company will fit into a selfie
and we're based out of Norway that's
what we have to care about this law this
is a Norwegian fjords for you if in case
you were doubting where we were from
Norway and so as its mentioned what
we're trying to do is I just to give you
a little bit of context what we're
trying to do is to make a super easy
video calling so the thing is and is
that it's in the browser so you can just
like send someone a link and they can
open it on any device and then you're in
the call oh I have to be careful with a
clicker here yeah in the call so the
thing is and there's a couple of people
that do this but why colours comes into
this is that the people that use our
service our businesses or professionals
so could for instance be your physician
there's offering video appointments
maybe you have a cold like I have today
actually and maybe you want to talk you
a therapist even though you're
travelling or maybe sometimes you would
want to learn something from a
professional and the person was best
suited to teach you this it's on the
other side of the world like if I want
to learn Japanese it's probably better
to get a teacher that's in Japan and the
thing also these people they have the
brands you know they already have
businesses so if they're going to offer
the services they would like to brown
their video calls so just to give you a
little bit more like an image of who our
client could be this is Siri she's
amazing Siri funk-rock she's a midwife
she's been running giving advice to
people about pregnancy and newborns for
like on the instant almost 20 years now
this is a Google it's called everything
from mom doctor I know this is a Google
Translate so this is what she does she
knows she's the mid-foot she knows
everything about giving advice as a
midwife she doesn't she's not a designer
she's not a developer so maybe cuz she
lets people ask questions about
pregnancy online maybe that's a good
format for video too
okay so it's the case so okay how does
this what does this have to do with
accessibility so let's look wheel it all
up the thing is if you let people brand
something the first thing you would
think of is Cola but if we let people
pick any Cola
what about the contrasts in a bunch of
services I'm not here to bash just to
give some well-known examples if you for
instance avoid shoes our gel yellow for
my profile at Twitter that the contrast
is not good enough or if I choose yellow
for our intercom messenger the contrast
really isn't good enough I have to pick
another color to make sure that the
contrast is sufficient and then then I
and I have to know that that's specialty
knowledge you know what contrast is not
everybody knows that so here we are CEO
I was like well I won't post I wanted to
pee can we just let people just pick any
color and then we just make sure that is
accessible so the questionnaire for my
CEO and then us in will our senior
engineer Ivan isn't a designer and
looking and I was also here because I
took the photo yeah so that's was the
thing that were we trying to figure out
okay but to get everyone on the same
page I think a lot of us know that
intuitively colors have contrast towards
each other but what does actually the V
CAG requirements say for contrast color
so it says that the visual presentation
of text and images of text has to have a
contrast ratio of at least four point
five to one and for large text the same
requirement is three to one one of the
new things now is that in 2.1
specification that just came out also
non-text elements like interface
elements buttons and the likes and icons
also have to have sufficient contrast
ratio
but yeah so what exactly is contrast so
it turns out that contrast has a
definition but together that it's
important to understand one thing first
and that is that according to V CAG
every single color has what's called
their relative luminance or a lightness
ratio basically telling you how light a
color is from 0 which is pitch black to
1 which is bright white and get the
contrast between two colors you do it
like this so you take the luminance of
the lighter color plus a constant 0.05
that's just to avoid any division by
zero issues and stuff like that and then
I divide that by the luminance of the
darker color like here and that gives
you the color contrast ratio to give you
a proper example let's look at this
button right here it's the yellow button
with black text on it so together the
contrast ratio between the text color
and the background here we take the
luminance of the yellow and divide that
by the luminance of the black and we
arrive at 12.4 as we know that is larger
than 4.5 which means that this has
sufficient contrast according to
requirement and according to the law
actually researching this and
understanding what where that number
came from was just so cuz we always put
it into some calculator no yeah that's
the right number ones like but where
does it come from now we know and so the
thing is this there's nothing really
wrong with this yellow button this is
our default it's just and then maybe
someone comes along that's like a doctor
or something doctors like blue and there
Brian color is dark blue and now it's
suddenly kind of hard to read the button
but if you're a designer and you've met
so this is a quite easy solution to this
from a design perspective let's just
flip the call of the text of the button
to white and said and then the contrast
is sufficient and then we were trying to
thinking about well what about grey does
would it will will it work for
everything but actually if you think
about the math that we just went to when
the criteria is 4.5 if you have either
black text or white text it will
actually validate against any color Eve
any color your shade of gray will either
violate against white or a black so
there you have the solution maybe you
can just fix that for me sure okay so
you and I we sat down and we started
going about this problem and we started
thinking this is way before we knew
anything about color contrast or how
that was defined I started thinking what
if we could do math on colors wouldn't
that be kind of cool
I mean intuitively colors in computing
are bits or numbers you should be able
to do calculations on numbers right and
it turns out we're not the first one to
think of this there's an NPM package for
that actually because of course there's
an NPM package for that so the NPM
package color lets you do a lot of cool
stuff with colors it can manipulate or
convert colors it can rotate them it can
mix them with other colors you can check
your lightness ratio you can also test
their VK color contrast and more but
there's one problem here all of this is
in JavaScript and we don't really want
to do all these calculations for every
single component on our entire page
ideally we'd want to do this once and
then apply that or store that in some
kind of variable that we can use in our
sauce sheets and as Mike just told you
we can do that now so just in case you
are out for that talk I'm gonna go run
through it for like one minute and just
tell you the basics again so CSS custom
properties allows you to define
variables in CSS basically you know that
means you can reuse color definitions
and more that can be complex values
throughout your stylesheet and they are
cascading and they can be overwritten
the syntax looks like this used a double
dash notation to define our custom
property and you assign it a value then
you can use that using the VAR keyword
like so you can also manipulate these
from JavaScript using the set property
function the first argument is the name
of the custom property and of second one
is the value this also works for inline
styles if you're using JSX that is one
approach you can use as well I think
that's pretty nice
but back to our problem so to solve this
first things first we should import the
color library then we create an instance
of the of color with our brand color or
whatever brown color
the customer wanted it can either be
hard-coded like here or do like us we
load it from the back end and apply it
asynchronously at runtime for our entire
application then we can simply check if
the primary color is white and if it is
the contrast color is designed to black
and if it isn't is assigned to white
then we simply set that using the set
property tag back to your CSS and in
your button component you set the
background color with war and a text
color to the contrast color like so and
automatically updates now there's a
bunch of different best use cases here
and Mike talked a lot about those but be
diligent and use custom variables
throughout if you're going for this
approach for theming otherwise you get
into issues later and such sensible
defaults to avoid any flash of and water
content what's neat about this is that
when we change this at runtime
everything updates at the same time
which is very good so that was a bunch
of buttons and that was the talking
thanks for coming or wait a second the
thing is what we have guaranteed now is
that you will always be able to read the
text on the button but what if someone
comes along and they have a really light
Frank color where did that button go so
even you can still read the text your
mail might not even understand that it
is a button at all so the thing that we
figure then is well what we would
typically do and maybe what if we could
have like a darker version of the same
color and add an outline so that we will
be sure that people will still see the
button even if the brown color is really
light you want to fix that too right so
this problem is a bit more complex right
because there's actually two problems
here first we need to generate a
secondary color now a darker primary
color which is as close to a primary
color as possible
but still validates against our
background color which in this case is
white and the second problem is that we
want to add a conditional border that
only gets applied if the primary color
is lighter than the current minimum
constant ratio how do you do that well
remember colors yes again so I told you
that it allows you to mix colors and
test contrast oh I was supposed to click
here yeah so but intuitively if you want
to make a darker color in real life this
is the first problem if you have a
palette with a color that you want to
make darker you take a little bit of
black and mix that in until you get the
desired color there are sort of the
thing for that
okay so let's try to make a function
that can do this for us is that a
function get validate the color takes a
couple of arguments it takes the color
that we want to change in this case our
primary color it takes the color that we
want to validate against it defaults to
white there's the minimum contrast ratio
that we want to achieve and it takes a
mixing amount mmm this is 0.5 it's quite
important that this is cool it's a bit
low because imagine the same palette
that you had earlier and you take a
bucket of black paint and pour it all
over the end result is going to be black
and you made a mess right so that's not
gonna work you have to do it in small
baby steps to get a proper color and
then of course last you take the mixing
color so let's look at the body of this
function so first things let's generate
a new color using the mix function so if
the color to want to change mix and we
mixed up with the mixing color and the
mixing amount then we check if the new
colors contrast towards white is less
than a minute constant ratio and if it
is we call the function again this time
with a new color as the color we want to
change and a smaller mixing amounts we
just do it very very close until
eventually we get a color that validates
against white
someone engineers serum I think well
haven't you made a function that could
potentially run forever and the thing is
that black will always validate against
white lease for the minimum conscious
ratio there is no chance that this
actually running forever you always end
up with a color that does validate
against white and once we have that we
can simply call the function with a
primary color and get the primary color
darker primary color back and we set
that back into our CSS so onto our next
problem adding a conditional button
border how would you does well in the
normal case there is no border at all so
let's tackle that problem first so we
create a custom variable custom property
that has the button border which has the
default value of none and then we assign
that to the border property of our
button and now presto we have a button
with no border but in our CSS we can say
if the primary colors contrast against
white is less than minimum constant
ratio update that property and set it to
2 pixels solid and our second or are
darker primary color and that means that
now we have a conditional border that
will only show up if the color that the
customer set is less than the minimum
contact ratio so just to sum it up a
little bit so for instance if we have
the Year color yellow we will generate
lighter and darker versions of that
because we also you suffer other
interface moments like hovering and
stuff like that if we have a darker
color we would change the text to white
and then also have the lighter in the
darker if the color is really light we
add a border and also have these lighter
and darker ones but then you know so
they're doing the math in the back here
and mean the design you're working
together and you would also think well
aren't you done now what more is there
like how many colors you really need on
the website and this time I was like
well what about secondary colors and you
should never base any functionality on a
color alone because of colorblindness
but for people that do see the whole
spectrum it can actually be kind of
confusing if everyone thing is like
really strong in the same yellow it's
gonna be overwhelming
and and he's like if we have a brand you
typically have more colors and I'm I
really rolled in the companies to work
with user friendliness and usability in
UX and they're like oh my god I'm trying
to imagine how I'm gonna explain to you
sir yeah pick one color and we're gonna
use this for that and pick another color
maybe is gonna use this for that and
like it was like this is never gonna
wouldn't work just we have to make it so
simple if we just ask them for one color
and every we just fix the other one so
again we're looking well we've figured
these other things out how can we go
about can we try to generate the
secondary colors somehow and so just to
give you an example this is like our
default colors so what we would want
we're using the secondary colors here
for instance if there's a notification
or like a warning or something like that
so ideally we want to color the face
with the original brown color that
doesn't crash too much but it also seems
like a different color and when you
think about it like looks nice together
it's kind of different where's the
where's the math in that the other ones
required clear was like is that is there
a number for that looks nice together if
it's kinda different and so I just we
were discussing trying to like bullet
has to be a pattern here so we discussed
this with our design you like so when
you make brands you know from the ground
up how do you go about choosing the
secondary colors and you started talking
about color wheels and there's like a
bunch of different people for hundreds
of years people have thought about
colors and concept of color wheels it's
not really important what color wheel
we're talking about they're just the
concept of color wheels and the thing
isn't how all of these are represented
if you go on the top here and then you
try to move what he said it's like well
I try to just move slightly down the
circle until we find something that
looks like a new color but it still goes
good together you know so you don't go
all the way around the circle could then
is gonna look quite horrible and then
I'm gonna introduce you to on your color
wheel these are quite old but then here
we have the HSL color wheel so HSL color
is built up by tree values you have Q
which is a degree from 0 to 360 degrees
so that's important for us and RL
saturation and then we have lightness so
actually this color wheel expresses
exactly what our designer was talking
about because what if we could just
rotate to hue so for instance if we
repair the brown color is red we would
rotate it and we're like and some I
discussed this with like a developer
like how did you come up with this
number of sixty degrees just like no we
just went with sixty degrees that's just
like a gut feeling thing so like there's
no math behind sixty that's just
intuition that's just competence of our
designer six degrees we looked around
the circle like yeah that's gonna work
and you know mid there was the math
there after all yeah so going into this
we thought well this is gonna be super
hard to do but turns out it really isn't
because you just use only color jazz you
can use to rotate property and get
another color and what it does
essentially is just add the hue degrees
in CSS and actually funny thing is we've
been fretting about this talk for maybe
two months now and try to go over and
find stuff we could improve never meet
Mike earlier and then we've been talking
about but he shows me this demo I've
actually can do all of this in CSS and
I'm like damn it I wish I'd done that
I've told her that before yeah so with
this you get a secondary color you can
set that back into our CSS and we can
also use the same functions to generate
darker or lighter variants of that as
well okay so now we have a bunch of
rules how can you actually bring that
back in together into a team engine so
what we did is they created a rack
component that we call theme and what
this component does is that it takes a
property brown color which we load
asynchronously and it uses that to
calculate all other colors according to
our rule sets and when working this like
this it's important to remember that you
never hard-coded values anywhere here
CSS you always use CSS custom properties
because what you get out of it is a
single style sheet that is infinitely
brandable we can apply to any color and
it gives you a decent result back
and it also means that you can do a lot
of cool performance things for example
you don't have to do server-side
rendering to generate a new CSS for
every single customer you can just store
one value and then apply it at runtime
this means you can cache at CSS forever
for example you can also do critical
path rendering and stuff like that and
you don't have to do that for every
single organization you might serve and
using the thing component looks like
this
so theme applies all these custom
properties to its own element and thanks
to CSS when we wrap our entire Apple
component in it every rule will or every
color will apply to every component ins
and outs and this is also infinitely
nests table so for example we want to
give a rich preview the updates in real
time for the customer to see how their
color looks in real time we can do that
we just wrap the preview in a new theme
component and it doesn't affect anything
else on the page which is really neat
yeah yeah so the thing is now we could
like to confidently say to see yeah just
pick any color you like it's not her job
to think about the accessibility law
that's our job and what I think is
really fun here is that when we put in
her brand color which is pink look can
you see this automatically generated
secondary color there in the progress
bar and then look at her logo so the
algorithm actually went for a secondary
color that's basically the same that was
already in her logo so it's like it's
something's nice to have a designer and
your team they just give you the
algorithm that's how you make your
brands oh maybe not that easy but anyway
so this is a with the simple thing now
like if people pick different colors it
still has like really this clear picture
of their brand it looks very differently
depending on the color that you pick but
it's still the same elements and really
like brings the brand forward so of
course there's gonna be a demo so now if
you can pray to the demo god I promised
myself I would never do a live demo on
stage and I'm gonna do it anyway and
gonna work I promise yeah so here we
build a tester that lets you test out
all these colors using the color picker
for input and you can see in real time
here that now we have applied the border
property live and if ever example go
here you have some darker colors and it
works you can see all the code if you
scroll down you see the buttons - yeah
ok so here are some test things so even
if I pick bright white that actually
works and you can rotate this around and
it's really fast and snappy thanks - we
only do this once we started into CSS
and it automatically updates everywhere
and we can try looking at with
colorblindness - yeah so we have a
what's it called again
oh yeah but if I click there we go oh
yes let's try for example red week yeah
that works good how about monochromatic
yeah that looks good yeah so this also
works for different kinds of
colorblindness and so there's a link
where you can test this we'd be really
fun if like if someone manages to break
it or like find the color where the like
automatic thing just makes like a
there's a horrible job that would be fun
and just tweet us with it and like
there's a hole but it looks it doesn't
look that good with red I don't know
what's wrong with red than yellow
something the algorithm fails there yeah
definitely not done yeah so the thing is
so we're gonna leave this link up a
little bit hmm
so we've been talking here about
accessibility and accessibility law and
and of course important for me to just
underline it this means in the way that
I believe that our team is done with
accessibility and I don't think
accessibility is a thing that you can
never think of us done it's it's but it
does goes for everything that we do
online if it's performance or usability
and accessibility just has to be
intertwined with the work that you do
and something you do continuously but I
think that I want to come bring to you
is through this process it became really
clear to us that Jesus all right yeah
sorry he just pressed the keyboard what
I thought I saw the many on time
is that it's the team effort yes yes you
can see here a great time effort and
thanks so much better when you work
together someone gonna click the keys
for you but the thing is we we are and
we were an interdisciplinary team and I
don't think we would ever have come up
with the solution if we would have been
working on it on our own that's a
combination that made this possible and
I also want to I really love this law I
think it's wonderful I don't see it as
like a constraint or something oh no we
have to make it accessible it's not a
deterrent to us at all and I think that
for developers and or designers I think
would almost always really love with our
jobs it's this challenge it's like when
you get these puzzles like how am I
gonna solve this and suddenly you find
the aha moments and that's such a
satisfying feeling and accessibility can
give you a bunch of those and in that
perspective you know this is one of the
most fun things that I've done and and
and it's a good thing for someone let
that's like a bonus it's fun and you're
making the product accessible for more
people as I mentioned here like a demo
resource and yeah thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]